i was being asked to be john gotti's
hitman
if i refused
john gotti would kill me i understood
that
the key part of my plan was
to get georgie grosso drunk on drugs
to keep him loose
so there was no problem
killing him
i'm at the bar and georgie crosso walks
in i go hey george a
come on come over we're all having shots
and he goes i just want him to leave
earlier and just have one shot ain't
gonna kill you i have a shot
and once he puts down the first one
inside me i say okay i got him
once i have georgie drunk and high he's
going to want to continue to partying
and i tell georgie go shotgun
i sit right behind georgie grasso's seat
because from there
i'm going to choose where i think it's
comfortable to shoot him in the head
we're driving down this quiet road
and he's laughing and i'm laughing
as we're having that bent up somewhere
in the back of your conscience you're
saying
am i going to do this really am i going
to take this guy's life
[Music]
and then the other side of me is saying
you promised
you don't pay this order
somebody i trust is going to kill me too
and i'm nervous
can i really do this
[Music]
just do it
he's going to get killed one way or
another
i'm not getting killed for this guy
i finally picked up the gun
i stuck it around the head rest
and i just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody said anything
it kind of really hit me
wow this guy's gone
i really killed this guy
[Music]
as i look back on it
that was the biggest mistake i ever made
in my life
you just killed yourself with that
bullet although you're not in the ground
you just destroyed your life
[Music]
[Music]
you